[Music]
imagine a future where nobody dies
instead our minds are uploaded to a
digital world they might live on in a
realistic simulated environment with
avatar bodies and could still call in
and contribute to the biological world
mind uploading has powerful appeal but
what would it actually take to scan a
person's brain and upload their mind the
main challenges are scanning a brain in
enough detail to capture the mind and
perfectly recreating that detail
artificially but first we have to know
what to scan the human brain contains
about 86 billion neurons connected by at
least a hundred trillion synapses the
pattern of connectivity among the brains
neurons that is all of the neurons and
all their connections to each other is
called the connectome we haven't yet
mapped the connectome and there's also a
lot more to neural signaling there are
hundreds possibly thousands of different
kinds of connections or synapses each
functions in a slightly different way
some work faster some slower some grow
or shrink rapidly in the process of
learning some are more stable over time
and beyond the trillions of precise
one-to-one connections between neurons
some neurons also spray out
neurotransmitters that affect many other
neurons at once all of these different
kinds of interactions would need to be
mapped in order to copy a person's mind
there are also a lot of influences on
neural signaling that are poorly
understood or undiscovered to name just
one example patterns of activity between
neurons are likely influenced by a type
of cell called glia glia surround
neurons and according to some scientists
may even outnumber them by as many as 10
to 1 glia were once thought to be purely
for structural support and their
functions are still poorly understood
but at least some of them can generate
their own signals that influence
information processing our understanding
of the brain isn't good enough to
determine what we'd need to scan in
order to replicate the mine
but assuming our knowledge does advance
to that point how would we scan it
currently we can accurately scan a
living human brain with resolutions of
about half a millimeter using our best
non-invasive scanning method MRI to
detect a synapse we'll need to scan at a
resolution of about a micron a
thousandth of a millimeter to
distinguish the kind of synapse and
precisely how strong each synapse is
we'll need even better resolution MRI
depends on powerful magnetic fields
scanning at the resolution required to
determine the details of individual
synapses would require a field strength
high enough to cook a person's tissues
so this kind of leap and resolution
would require fundamentally new scanning
technology it would be more feasible to
scan a dead brain using an electron
microscope but even that technology is
nowhere near good enough and requires
killing the subject first assuming we
eventually understand the brain well
enough to know what to scan and develop
the technology to safely scan at that
resolution the next challenge would be
to recreate that information digitally
the main obstacles to doing so are
computing power and storage space both
of which are improving every year we're
actually much closer to attaining this
technological capacity than we are to
understanding or scanning our own minds
artificial neural networks already run
our internet search engines digital
assistants self-driving cars Wall Street
trading algorithms and smartphones
nobody has yet built an artificial
network with 86 billion neurons but as
computing technology improves it may be
possible to keep track of such massive
data sets at every step in the scanning
and uploading process we'd have to be
certain we were capturing all the
necessary information accurately or
there's no telling what ruined version
of a mind might emerge while mind
uploading is theoretically possible
we're likely hundreds of years away from
the technology and scientific
understanding that would make it a
reality and that reality would come with
ethical and philosophical consider
Asians who would have access to mind
uploading what rights would be accorded
to uploaded minds how could this
technology be abused even if we can
eventually upload our minds whether we
should remains an open question the
educator of this lesson has an exciting
idea about the biological basis for
consciousness
check out rethinking consciousness for a
fresh perspective on your perspective
[Music]